tens of thousands of people are
demonstrating in the Palestinian
territories to demand the right to
return to Israel and an end to Israel's
blockade of the Gaza Strip organizers
are calling today's events a million-man
March it's also the one-year anniversary
of the start of weekly protests in Gaza
two Palestinians have been killed in
clashes with Israeli forces near the
Gaza border the Palestinian Red Crescent
says more than 100 were injured
including bullet wounds and tear gas
inhalation there's also been violence in
the city of Ramallah in the West Bank
joining us now from Jerusalem is DW is
Tanya Kaymer Tanya Gaza health ministry
officials say two Palestinians have been
killed by Israeli fire today what can
you tell us yes that's right
one young man succumbed AXYZ injuries he
sustained last night in protest on
Friday night he died early this morning
and another 17 year old teenager was hit
during the afternoon directly in the
face it's unclear whether it was by
sniper fire of a tear gas canister and
died from his injuries also question has
said that over a hundred people were
injured most of them however likely
which is what you've seen over the past
year at demonstrations of this scale
it's it's rather a lower number than
what we've seen now there have been
reports that there have been some kind
of unofficial and understandings
brokered by an Egyptian delegation has
been shuttling between Gaza and Israel
over the past week between Hamas and
Israel to calm down the situation the
organizers of these protests have asked
protestors to stay far away from the
fence the Israeli army has put out a
statement said there had been some young
protesters approaching the fence
throwing some stones and some devices
but most of the protesters have actually
stayed further away from the fence
tanja in ten days you know better better
than the NIE there are two general
elections in Israel do you think the
clashes will have any influence
on the outcome of the vote well I think
all eyes were actually on this day today
after week of heightened tensions that
started with a rocket being launched and
landing and central Israel on a home of
a family with injuries there and then
they had been cross a border fire for
overnight and ever since the Egyptian
delegation had been trying to mediate
between indirectly obviously between
Hamas and Israel Prime Minister
Netanyahu has been put in a tight spot
on how to respond he has vowed to have a
tough response all his opponents have
called on really tough response against
Gaza so all of this of course happening
in the middle of an election campaign so
all eyes were on Gaza today what is
happening how this table unfold and of
course whatever happens here on the
ground will also affect the remaining
election campaign with elections
happening on April 9th okay DWS tenure
clamor in Jerusalem thank you for that